en août 1944 Adolf Hitler a bien donné
l'ordre de détruire Paris mais la
capitale ne doit pas comme le veut la
légende en général allemand von
choletats d'avoir été épargné quant aux
dictateur nazi là en réalité chercher
jusqu'à l'automne 1944 à faire de Paris
un champ de ruine voilà ce qui est
avancé dans ce documentaire et ce dont
nous allons débattre maintenant avec nos
invités dans ce débat doc en commençant
par celle qui a réalisé le film que nous
venons de voir cette enquête historique
Françoise de fabrique bienvenue à vous
vous êtes donc une réalisatrice de
documentaire passionnée d'histoire vous
venez de le prouver dans ce film que
nous venons de voir ce film détruire
Paris les plans secrets d'Hitler dont
nous allons tout de suite bien sûr
reparler ensemble Olivier wigert cake
également à nos côtés bienvenue à vous
vous êtes historien spécialiste de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale votre dernier
livre s'intitule Les grandes erreurs de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et c'est un
ouvrage disponible chez Perrin et puis
enfin avec nous en webcam cette fois et
depuis Berlin Fabien Théophile acquise
bienvenue à vous bonjour vous êtes
également historiens spécialiste du
nazisme auteur entre autres de ce livre
les prisonniers de guerre allemand
France
1944-1949 c'est un ouvrage disponible
chez Fayard merci à vous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je m'adresse tout de
suite à vous après avoir vu ce film vous
dynamiter littéralement la légende du
général van celtilts celui qui aurait
sauvé Paris en août 1944 comment vous
devez une cette idée comment avez-vous
ce doute sur cette légende van Chelsea
alors évidemment paris brûle-t-il le
livre et le film ont bercé mon enfance
et mon adolescence c'est une telle
épopée qu'on a vraiment envie d'y croire
et d'ailleurs j'y ai cru
et puis j'ai fait des études d'histoire
et j'ai vraiment compris que l'histoire
n'est pas les événements historiques ne
sont pas jamais liés à un seul élément
ou à la volonté d'un seul homme mais
c'est toujours plus réfactoriel et puis
ensuite cette histoire me paraissait
beaucoup trop linéaire et beaucoup trop
romanesque pour être vrai
malheureusement
on s'est rendu compte que les histoires
sont toujours un peu moins jolies en
tout cas c'est souvent le cas que ce
qu'on voudrait bien croire et donc c'est
vrai que j'ai j'ai cherché en fait j'ai
lu pas mal de d'historiens qui sont
intéressés à la libération de Paris et
tous s'accordaient à dire plus ou moins
que ce rôle avait été si sinon si non
exagéré du moins carrément inventé et
mais je ne trouvais pas l'épreuve de ce
que j'avançais je voulais pas faire un
film qui restituait une parole sans
avoir été vraiment la chercher sur des
bases
solides et que je pouvais à mon tour
apporter des preuves et c'est vrai que
comme j'ai fait ces études d'histoire
j'ai acquis une certaine méthodologie
qui m'ont permis d'aller chercher dans
les archives d'aller trouver m'associer
avec un historien allemand pour lui
demander des recherches très précises
j'avais quelques fois l'impression de
chercher une aiguille dans une botte de
foin mais finalement j'ai trouvé les
documents et même en France aussi
vous êtes allé à aux archives de la
préfecture de Paris ça c'est pour les
pour en avoir le cœur net sur ce qui
était l'état des un des minages des
différents monuments de Paris c'est là
qu'on apprend que la Tour Eiffel n'a
jamais été n'a jamais été minée par
exemple dans votre documentaire puis
vous avez été également à Fribourg
consulter les archives militaires du
Troisième Reich j'imagine que la pioche
était importante vous avez trouvé ce que
vous avez voulu trouver à Fribourg vous
nous avez tout dit dans ce documentaire
vous nous a rien caché il y aurait pas
quelque chose en plus que vous auriez
trouvé et qui n'aurait pas été dit dans
ce film non non
j'ai mis toutes les archives que j'avais
trouvé alors Olivier vivorka vous avez
vous jetez votre garde historien
spécialiste la Seconde Guerre mondiale
sur ce film est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette thèse et étayer qui
plus est à travers cette enquête selon
laquelle ventolite n'est qu'une légende
finalement oui alors tout à fait d'abord
c'est un très beau documentaire très
bien fait très rigoureux donc de ce
point de vue là on ne peut qu'avoir de
l'admiration pour pour ce film de
l'autre et c'est le seul bémol que je me
permets d'introduire c'est que tous les
généraux allemands sont des gros
menteurs il faut quand même le dire
c'est-à-dire que l'idée qui a été on
affirme très souvent que l'histoire est
écrite par les vainqueurs c'est un lieu
commun je crois qu'on peut dire aussi
qu'elle a été très souvent écrite par
les vaincus et dans ce storytelling ce
roman national on a eu jusqu'aux années
80 l'idée qu'on avait une vermarte
propre qui se battait de manière
chevaleresque avec des généraux qui
n'étaient pas nazis mais qui faisait au
fond leur travail de généraux et qu'il
n'avait rien à voir avec la Shoah avec
les massacres et dans ce dans ce
panthéon il y avait sol tits à qui nous
devions au fond tant et ce que montre
bien le documentaire c'est que c'est
totalement inexact mais c'est totalement
inexact comme lorsqu'on affirme que
romelle mène une guerre sans haine en
Afrique du Nord
queenstein n'en rien responsable des
persécutions antisémites en crimées non
c'est généraux c'était l'armée de Hitler
et c'était des généraux nazis et ce
titre de ce point de vue ne dérange pas
la règle c'est vrai ce que vous dites il
y a quelque part peut-être une part de
de crédulité mais en même temps il faut
quand même comprendre que aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de fake news et ceux qui
qui voit ses fake news et qu'on
conscience de leur quels sont erronées
ne comprennent pas que cette suivie et
aujourd'hui il y a les réseaux sociaux à
l'époque le livre de von choltits est un
mensonge et il est relayé non pas par
des réseaux sociaux mais par la lit et
le cinéma et donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui était ancré très
profondément dans les consciences et et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut dire que
c'était une grosse fake news et ça ça
résonne beaucoup avec l'actualité alors
on va voir un premier extrait avant de
rejoindre notre invité depuis Berlin de
votre film c'est la fin d'ailleurs on
est à Baden Baden dans les années 60 et
voilà comment est présenté le général
ventualité
dans une villa de Baden Baden vie
l'homme qui fut du côté allemand au
centre des heures dramatiques de la
libération de Paris il y a 20 ans cet
homme le général fun sheltips était le
dernier gouverneur militaire allemand du
Grand Paris il fut celui qui aurait pu
réduire la capitale ensemble
ça c'est un extrait qui a été diffusé
dans les actualités qu'on passait dans
les cinémas français dans les années 60
Fabien Théophile à qui je me tourne vers
vous il y a aussi une légende votre site
en Allemagne il y a aussi une réécriture
de l'histoire du côté elle est vaincu
comme vient de le dire Olivier vivier le
concernant
ce que je peux dire par rapport au point
de vue allemand c'est que les vaincus
sont les vainqueurs de demain je veux
dire par assez généreux là s'ils
écrivent c'est la mémoire c'est pas
seulement pour une défense personnelle
c'est à travers la défense de la vermark
de
on prépare le réarmement en 55 de la
pundes verts et dans le documentaire
vous avez un homme c'est anspaidel qui
est un général allemand général spiddle
il finit après sa libération de
captivité comme conseiller militaire
auprès d'Eden hour et finit sa carrière
comme chef des forces terrestres de
l'OTAN et donc c'est l'intégration
absolument parfaite réussie de
l'Allemagne mais qui peut se faire qu'au
prix d'un énorme mensonge je sais pas
mais l'histoire qui a pour but de dire
il y a les mauvais allemands qui sont
les SS qui ont fait d'être cité les bons
Allemands ont été obligés d'obéir ils
ont combattu de façon propre à l'Est et
en ce sens là c'est les gens là sont une
face une sorte de politique d'État qui
vise à réintégrer l'Allemagne dans
l'OTAN et dans l'Europe alors autre
question très factuelle cette fois on
évoque paris brûle-t-il c'est évidemment
le titre du livre qui est sorti en
1965 qui était signé d'ailleurs par deux
journalistes
Larry Collins d'une part et Dominique
Lapierre d'autre part puis il en a été
tiré cette super production
hollywoodienne avec un casting vraiment
véritablement éblouissant Jean-Paul
Belmondo Kurt Douglas Alain Delon Michel
Piccoli Orson Welles sa tournée dans
paris brûle-t-il cette fameuse phrase
paris brûle-t-il c'est la phrase
qu'aurait adressée Hitler avant que le
titre peut-être le 24 août 1944 pour
s'assurer que ces ordres avaient bien
été respectés Latil véritablement
prononcé cette phrase Hitler
moi je n'ai pas la réponse parce que je
n'ai pas vu le j'essaie de chercher de
mon côté je n'ai pas vu le le Télégramme
donc envoyé depuis son QG ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il y en a un qui finit par si
Paris doit être tombé aux mains de
l'ennemi il doit tomber comme un champ
de ruine donc l'image de la ruine et
fondamentale on pourra revenir pourquoi
parce que je pense que les nazis dans
l'imaginait en Asie la ruine a une
position très particulière mais sur la
phrase
brain Paris ça j'ai pas trouvé il y a
tout de même une certitude c'est que
hitler voulait bel et bien détruire
Paris réduire notre capital ensemble
pourquoi cette obsession du côté de
d'Adolf Hitler alors c'est intéressant
parce que c'est pas une obsession au
départ quand Hitler vient à Paris en
1940 il y a à Paris en vainqueur avec au
moins trois vidéos le premier c'est
quand même que Paris et la depuis 19e
siècle la perle de la civilisation une
ville de culture et en 41 il dit
clairement il a aucun état d'âme aucun
état d'âme a été à détruire Varsovie
Saint-Pétersbourg Moscou mais il est
très content de ne pas avoir détruit en
40 Paris alors pourquoi il le fait en 44
je pense qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'il le fait dans un imaginaire nazi
qui n'est pas un peu comme la firme le
film une sorte de chant du signe
irrationnel dans l'imaginaire nazi si
l'Allemagne doit perdre la guerre
militairement et bien son ennemi réditer
militaire qui est la France doit aussi
perdre et je dirais que si celui qui
tient Paris tient la France et bien
celui qui perd Paris il perd la France
et donc si l'Allemagne fait la guerre
Paris doit payer les conséquences et
c'est à ce moment-là ton site imaginaire
que il est très clairement quel que soit
l'issue de la guerre et bien même si on
perd Paris va retrouver son rang qui
devait avoir c'est à dire un rang de 5e
puissance mondiale et donc la
destruction de Paris est dans un email
nazi se met en place quand la défaite
devient impossible pour l'Allemagne
elle-même alors avec le général von
chelties vous dynamité aussi une autre
légende
qui s'appelle Raoul Nordling qui était
le consul suédois présent à Paris et les
deux hommes ont eu des entretiens assez
fréquents entre l'arrivée de vanchelty à
Paris au début du mois d'août et c'est
la libération de Paris qui intervient le
25 août 44 Raoul Nordling vous avez été
vérifié dans ces mémoires il n'a jamais
eu cette très longue conversation qu'on
lui attribue notamment dans le film et
la pièce de théâtre qui a été tiré de
cet entretien qui s'appelle diplomatie
ou deux acteurs principaux d'ailleurs
jouent ce film Niels altrude d'une part
qui joue le général van Celtics et André
Dussollier qui jouit le rôle de de ce
fameux consul suédois ça n'a jamais
existé non plus alors les rencontres
entre ont existé bien sûr notamment pour
parler du sort des prisonniers notamment
pour parler de la famine qui régnait à
Paris et essayer de de laisser la Croix
Rouge entrée pour pouvoir aller nourrir
toutes ces populations etc et également
au sujet du sort des parisiens mais en
fait plus que de celui des monuments ou
plus parce que ce que craignait beaucoup
entre les deux hommes c'est la
destruction de la capitale parce que
craignait beaucoup Nordine et d'ailleurs
les Parisiens aussi c'était des
représailles des représailles massives
contre la population donc des
discussions certes il y en a eu
mais pas du tout celle qu'on leur prête
et d'ailleurs aussi bien schlender qui a
fait diplomatie que
René Clément je ne sais plus mais en
tout cas scholder c'est certain il dit
et c'est vrai que là c'est intéressant
de voir comment le cinéma peut avoir
aussi des conséquences sur finalement le
savoir collectif quand les gens sur
l'histoire la perception qu'ils en ont
bien que ça soit des heures artistiques
malgré tout quand ils se permettent des
libertés on a des conséquences sur un
plan purement factuel Olivier virtuel
l'insurrection de Paris commence le 19
août ce qui est avancé dans ce
documentaire vous paraît tout à fait
plausible c'est-à-dire sont les avancées
à la fois cette insurrection parisienne
d'une part et là on sait des troupes
alliés sur Paris qui expliquerait qu'on
n'est pas pu que n'aurait pas pu
exécuter les ordres d'Hitler oui tout à
fait la bonne version selon vous à mon
avis oui le documentaire est de ce point
de vue tout à fait convaincant vous avez
une insurrection qui qui se développe à
partir du 19 août 1944 mais cette
insurrection elle n'est pas capable de
prendre la ville elle peut créer une
forme d'insécurité mais elle n'est pas
capable de prendre la ville et donc du
coup il faut le secours des armées
régulières et notamment de la deuxième
DB du général Leclerc mais également des
forces américaines et c'est bien tout le
sens de la mission que le patron des FFI
des résistants d'Île-de-France rôle
Tanguy assigne au commandant Gallois on
lui demandant d'aller voir les alliés
pour qu'ils envoient le plus vite
possible le plus vite possible donc
comment dirais-je des renforts
sachant que si choltite veut
effectivement dynamiter la ville il ne
tient pas à se battre dans la ville le
grand intérêt de scholti c'est ça il
faut le répéter c'est qu'il tient à
tenir les ponts il tient à tenir les
ponts pour que les forces allemandes
puissent retraiter il n'est pas du tout
question de jouer à Paris la partition
qui a été jouée à Stalingrad de combat
de rue tout simplement parce que les
combats d'Horus sont meurtriers non
seulement pour les assaillants mais pour
les défenseurs que les rares atouts qui
subsistent les tanks les canons sont
impraticables et donc une bataille de
runes aurait eu aucun sens donc la
grande obsession c'est de tenir les
ponts et de faciliter la retraite et
comme l'expliquer Fabien théophileakis
et comme on le voit dans le film
effectivement dynamité ce qui fait la
beauté de la ville de Paris oui parce
qu'il faut distinguer ce que sont les
objectifs qui pourraient considérés
comme des objectivités vous évoquez les
ponts dans un certain nombre d'entre eux
ont été préparés en tout cas pasminer
mais préparer on va les citer c'est le
pont de Neuilly le pont de Joinville le
pont de Saint-Cloud le pont Alexandre
III là on en a la certitude ils étaient
préparé mais mais non minet mais enfin
avant que effectivement il y avait des
bâtiments qui n'avaient aucun intérêt
stratégique on part évidemment on pense
au palais Bourbons ici qui a été le
bâtiment le plus minet de Paris par par
les amants mais aussi le Sénat le fort
de Jarron de Charenton le ministère de
la Marine et la Porte de Saint-Cloud
notamment avec la gare du Bourget donc
il a il est très clair qu'il n'y a pas
que des objectifs militaires dans dans
cette liste non tout à fait ceci dit si
les Allemands ne veulent pas engager des
combats de rue c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle Eisenhower ne veut pas
prendre Paris au départ il faut le
souligner le plan visait à contourner
Paris tout simplement parce que
Eisenhower non plus ne voulait pas que
des combats de rue s'engagent parce que
également ils craignait ce que vous
venez d'évoquer toutes les difficultés
inhérentes au ravitaillement de la ville
lumière il ne voulait pas que ce fardeau
incombe aux forces alliées donc l'idée
était de contourner Paris pour que Paris
au fond tombe comme un frimeur Fabien
Théophile acquise voulait rajouter
peut-être quelque chose à ce qui vient
d'être dit il faut ajouter préciser un
petit peu sur la il faut bien distinguer
je pense de niveau la tactique et puis
les raisons de ces ordres là quand je
t'ai nommé par Hitler pour venir
remplacer celui qui part au cross Paris
c'est il est nommé c'est important comme
bettels Harbor c'est à dire que Hitler
dans cette nouvelle tentative de tenir
les pointes
stratégique transforme ces villes en
forteresse et les personnes qui ont le
pouvoir de gérer on va pouvoir bien
au-delà de leur rendre hiérarchique et
donc l'idée c'est que il arrive et que
dans l'idée de Hitler Paris soit ce
qu'il appelle je fais à Punk c'est à
dire le lieu pivot qui va tenir une
défense et très rapidement modèle
comprend qui est le chef des le chef des
armées à l'ouest que faire ça c'est en
fait compte signer la défaite de l'armée
allemande en France et ouvrir
l'Allemagne aux Alliés et donc en fin de
compte pour les Allemands très
rapidement sur place jamais Paris ne va
être le nœud stratégique de défense et
ça pose la question assez fondamentale
qui est bien montrée dans le
documentaire c'est en fin de compte
pourquoi il y a un tel décalage entre ce
que ordonne Hitler donc depuis
l'Allemagne et ce qui se passe dans ces
différents lieux où l'or n'est pas
jamais appliqué que ce soit en terme
donc de déminage ou des minages que ce
soit en terme de de bombardements et
donc là il faut bien comprendre qu'on a
la question que pose de documentaire et
qui a donné lieu à cette légende c'est
qu'il y a un tel décalage entre la
guerre imaginé par le Führer qui est en
dehors de la réalité et le lieu c'est
que ça donne une marge manoeuvre assez
importante assez généraux qui n'auraient
jamais fait ça en 41 42 ou 43
malgré tout est-ce qu'on peut dire que
Von Chelsea ça a voulu appliquer ses
ordres non je serais plutôt réservé sur
ce sur cette ce point là mais encore une
fois c'est très compliqué de faire la
part de la légende et puis de la réalité
il semblerait en revanche il y a
d'autres sources concordantes que ces
mémoires qui montrent que assez
rapidement d'une part quand il a après
rendez-vous et avec Hitler et qui prend
conscience qu'on a un fureur qui n'est
plus capable d'avoir le sens des
réalités et d'autre part les moyens
matériels et humains qu'il a sur place
que très rapidement il y a un tel
décalage que de toute façon les gens
sont pas réalisables et donc il va pas
le faire alors il avance une autre
raison qui est une raison typiquement de
raisonnement nazi qu'on appelle la
zipenheart c'est qu'il y a une loi en
Allemagne qui pour éviter les désertions
ou les généraux qui se rendent quand en
général est nommé on peut prendre sa
famille en otage et donc il a très peur
que sa famille si le monde trop
rapidement et trop visiblement qu'il va
pas obéir autant du Führer que sa
famille qui est à Baden-Baden soit
arrêté et donc son idée en partie c'est
de donner le change pour montrer qu'il
apparaît et c'est pour ça qu'il a été
nommé hein et nommé en 44 à Paris parce
que toute sa carrière donc militaire en
Italie donc à Rotterdam ou en Russie
c'est quelqu'un qui très voyellement a
toujours appliqué les ordres de fureur
et donc il va continuer à avoir cette
couverture pour manifestement ne pas
mais je pense que c'est moins l'avancée
allié et la précipitation que le fait
qu'on a compris que c'était pas
applicable et que si vous voulez sauver
sa peau pour l'après-guerre il avait
tout intérêt à ne pas apparaître comme
le bourreau de Paris et vous faisiez une
référence avec une rencontre entre lui
et Hitler qui a eu lieu au début du mois
d'août c'est bien ça oui pour le coup
c'est que il y a deux éléments qui
jouent c'est que il rencontre une
personne Hitler considérée que dans son
plan que Paris était tellement un point
important qu'il voulait absolument
rencontrer celui qui allait le diriger
ce n'était pas le cas auparavant et donc
il a cette rencontre et il dit très
clairement qu'il a une épave humaine
devant lui est-ce que c'est pas à
porterie qui va le raconter et d'autre
part on est dans une période après le 20
juillet 44 où vous avez ici un grand
enfin quand on épuration dans l'armée
qui rebat un peu les cartes par rapport
à ça mais là on a choisi assez
rapidement que bah d'une part l'ordre
donné n'est plus donné par quelqu'un qui
a toute sa tête et sur place il sera
très rapidement compte aussi bien en
voyant avec comme modèle qui est le
dernier des forces de l'Ouest que
militairement ça n'a aucun sens de
défendre ça ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que
il faut être aucun à mon avis aucun
aucune mauvaise conscience de le faire
comme il a fait un Rotterdam ou quand il
l'a fait à Sébastopol le problème c'est
pas de dire la ville s'il ne le fait pas
c'est que pour une poly militairement ça
n'a pas de sens de le faire et on a ici
l'idée de la fin de la guerre et la
semaine militaire qui vont jouer c'est
moins pour la beauté de Paris elle-même
que pour un quelqu'un qui alors par
rapport à ce que dit Olivier à mon avis
c'est un général de la Wehrmacht est-ce
que pour autant cette analyse je sais
pas parce qu'il n'a pas du tout cette
logique de destruction pour la
destruction en revanche il va appliquer
les ordres tel qu'il faudra tant que la
guerre peut-être gagner parce que c'est
la guerre pour l'Allemagne en revanche
lorsque la guerre est perdu
militairement pour lui il ne va pas
s'engager à appliquer des heures de la
terre brûlée qu'il a appliqué sans sans
couper rire en Pologne ou en Russie
alors dans la deuxième partie de votre
film c'est un autre aspect des choses
vous nous prouvez que au moins jusqu'à
l'automne 44 il y avait toujours cette
volonté de la part d'Hitler de détruire
Paris et qui au moins trois choses qui
sont passées au travers de l'histoire le
fameux bombardement du 27 août au soir
par 120 avions tout de même de la loup
de vaffeux c'était beaucoup d'avions à
cette période là du côté allemand et
puis d'autre part les fameuses V1 V2
qu'on essaiera côté allemand de
d'envoyer sur sur la capitale là aussi
vous avez fait des recherches dans quel
sens dans quel biais pour trouver ces
informations c'est toujours c'est
toujours les archives c'est à dire que
on m'intéressant vraiment à ce sujet moi
je suis pas une spécialiste de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
si j'ai les
méthodologies pour pouvoir mener des
recherches malgré tout moi mon travail
c'est de lire les historiens et souvent
j'essaye de justement de voir un peu de
lire les
les certaines comment dire les courants
les grands courants et c'est intéressant
de voir justement comment cette histoire
est racontée et et le bombardement en
fait partie donc j'ai fait des
recherches effectivement j'ai trouvé une
coupure de journal et puis j'ai essayé
de comprendre pourquoi sur bombardement
avait été passé sous silence de la même
manière dans les archives j'ai trouvé
les ordres pour tirer les V1
j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi et
puis pour les V2 c'est la même chose
donc en fait si vous voulez c'est
toujours des centaines de victimes qui à
chaque fois passent à la trappe de
l'histoire c'est en fait je crois que la
bombardement dans la région parisienne
dans la nuit du 26 août je crois que la
réalité était en fait beaucoup plus
forte que la légende c'est à dire que
avec avec paris brûle-t-il la légende
s'arrête à voncheltits mais et à la
libération de Paris on a l'impression
que aujourd'hui avec les lunettes
d'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que tout
était terminé le 25 ou le 26 mais c'est
pas ça c'est faux c'est complètement
faux et donc du coup
la réalité est beaucoup plus
intéressante que la légende et c'est ça
que je voulais montrer montrer que
justement tout ne s'arrêtait pas le 26
et qu'au contraire une autre une autre
histoire à aller commencer avec une
menace encore plus terrible
sur cette poursuite de cette volonté de
détruire Paris de la part d'Hitler on
apprend des choses dans ce film à beaux
yeux on découvre tout de même à la fois
ce bombardement du 26 on voit que Paris
n'est pas complètement sécurisé et puis
les V1 V2 aurait pu très bien faire des
milliers de victimes que c'était le cas
à Londres en 44 alors deux choses là où
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
c'est que au fond pour les Français
aujourd'hui
l'histoire s'arrête le 25 ou le 26 août
or il va falloir encore près d'une année
pour que les Soviétiques plantent le
drapeau rouge au fronton du Reichstag
donc ça a été beaucoup plus long que ce
que l'on croit et beaucoup plus long que
ce kaizenower croyait donc ça je pense
que c'est un élément important à
souligner et donc bien évidemment il y a
des victimes ceci dit léger correctif
même si les va et les V2 étaient
extrêmement angoissants pour les
populations il ne pouvait pas inverser
le cours de la guerre la large qu'il
portait était trop faible
le nombre de V1 et de V2 étaient
insuffisant donc de toute façon il y
aurait eu des dégâts mais les dégâts
infligés à Londres par les vins et les
V2 n'ont rien à voir avec les dégâts du
Blitz de 1940-1941 et déjà les dégâts du
Blitz n'ont pas mis l'Angleterre à
genoux donc les victimes civiles
auraient été effectivement importantes
ça aurait été un événement assez
traumatique mais cela n'aurait pas pu
bien entendu inverser le cours de la
guerre alors on va voir un deuxième
extrait ce sera le dernier de cette
émission et il concerne cette fois les
fameuses V2 et puis on revient ensuite à
Berlin retrouver Fabien théophileakis
deux semaines plus tard le 8 septembre
une explosion pulvérise 60 maisons un
quartier entier de la ville de
Maisons-Alfort à moins de 10 km de Paris
des dégâts matériels à peine croyable
pour une seule déflagration
Le Figaro qui relate l'événement par le
debris inattendus les sans supposer à un
engin supérieur au V1
on vient d'entendre Olivier viviorca
nous parler de la puissance de feu sans
jeu de mots des vins V2 à comparer à ce
qui était les bombardements qui
régnaient un peu partout en Europe de
l'Ouest à cette époque fallait les V1 on
fait tout de même quelques 6000 victimes
du côté de Londres c'était pas tout à
fait neutre évidemment mais la première
fusée V2 et on la prend dans ce
documentaire
Fabien Théophile acquise elle était bel
et bien destinée à Paris ce 8 septembre
1944 oui alors ces fameux V2 V1 alors
v2v1 c'est pour faire quel
les armes de représailles et du côté
allemand c'est ce fameux armes miracle
comme Hitler les célèbres encore le 31
janvier 45 dans son dernier discours
radio diffusé en Berlin c'est la
dernière façon de mobiliser une
population qui n'y croit plus pour ce
qu'on appelle à Andy la victoire finale
et très rapidement d'ailleurs le foyer
va retomber puisque certes ça les dégâts
importants ça terrorise une population
mais en aucune façon techniquement
militairement ça peut retourner la
guerre par rapport à ça c'est simplement
dans cette imaginaire et assez
intéressant du côté allemand avec un
régime qui a parfois des valeurs très
traditionnelles la technologie est
censée venir suppléer un
manque de un manque de soldat et un
manque de d'offensive maintenant je vois
juste revenir sur les chiffres qui ont
été avancés c'est à peu près 8000
victimes l'ensemble des victimes des va
et des vélos c'est considérable je pense
qu'à ces 8000 victimes fois jouer les
8000 victimes de compte concentration
qui ont travaillé dans des conditions
absolument atroces pour construire et là
on est bien dans un régime qui n'a aucun
mal à faire travailler des populations
qu'il a lui-même déporté en intérêt pour
faire des des armes de destruction et
dans le bombardement qui a été invoqué
dans le film on dit 200 à quelques
victimes c'était considérables mais vous
allez donc d'avion c'est-à-dire que
manifestement il y avait une volonté
dans l'ordre donné de bombardements de
ne pas toucher le cœur de Paris mais
seulement la la la banlieue ou la
périphérie et donc encore une fois à
l'échelle de la de l'exécution des
ordres il y a quand même ici une volonté
de pas appliquer directement aux
conséquat de façon conséquente étant de
fureur soyez juste préciser par rapport
à ça c'est qu'on regarde ces hommes là
on s'aperçoit que fans Chelsea model et
Bernard qui est le démineur qui est
envoyé depuis Berlin pour venir miner
Paris parce que il manque de de
spécialistes qu'on pense aussi à spydle
tout cela se connaissait avant la guerre
ou pendant la guerre donc on a ici quand
même un réseau d'hommes parce que pour
pouvoir peu à peu ne pas appliquer les
ordres de Hitler il faut quand même une
confiance dans des partenaires et donc
vous avez ici des hommes qui à travers
la campagne de Russie ou avant dans la
Wehrmacht ont appris à se connaître et
ça a certainement permis plus rapidement
le fait qu'on applique moins directement
les ordres de l'éclair que si on avait
face à soi un interlocuteur qui était un
inconnu
je crois que vous étiez pas tout à fait
d'accord et ce qui vient d'être dit
que j'ai rencontré qui est d'ailleurs
dans le film ce sont plutôt des tirs
d'ajustement en fait et qui s'approche
qui s'approche de Paris de plus en plus
alors peut-être qu'effectivement ça
n'aurait pas détruit complètement la
ville où ça n'aurait pas tué
tous les parisiens mais ça aurait pu
détruire des monuments ça aurait pu
quand même faire beaucoup de dégâts
aussi bien humain que patrimoniaux
et puis et puis moi je ne suis pas
d'accord non plus quand
c'est un échange d'entre vous c'est fait
et vous êtes là pour ça faut que je sois
clair quand je parle de là je parle du
langues de bombardement des avions pas
des vins et des V2 c'est pas les mêmes
personnes pour les avions qui sont donc
une vision locale et c'est là où je vous
dis que le danseur qui est le chef de
commandement en force de la escadrille
va accepter va de ce manque de contenus
est-ce que vous dites exactement dans le
même sens en revanche les vins et les V2
se sont pas les mêmes même heure de
commandement qui ne se connaissent pas
et eux ils vont bien essayer de viser le
centre de Paris et donc on a bien ces
deux logiques d'applications de l'ordre
entre des hommes qui sont sur place qui
connaitre la situation et qui se
connaissent et qui vont faire en sorte
pour des raisons plus ou moins
pragmatiques et jamais humanitaire
d'éviter le cœur de Paris et des autres
une équipe technique beaucoup plus aux
ordres du Führer qui elle va essayer de
viser Paris avec les vérins et les V2 en
revanche vous remettez pas en cause le
point principal de cette deuxième partie
de votre film qui est le fait que Hitler
jusqu'à l'automne 44 espérer bel et bien
détruire tout ou en partie Paris mais ça
depuis le départ Hitler a une obsession
militairement à l'ouest et de détruire
Paris il n'a pas pu faire sa guerre
Mania sa capitale donc de la nouvelle
Allemagne il ne faut pas que Paris
puisse rester pour bien avoir en tête
pour Hitler Paris c'est le symbole de
14-18 la ville de Paris qui n'a pas été
prise et qui aurait permis de gagner la
Grande Guerre et bien il est hors de
question que til l'Allemagne perd une
deuxième fois la guerre Paris sorte
indemne de
[Musique]
parce que quand on compare les deux
mémoires celle de Nordling et celle de
scholtits on voit bien que qu'il y a
aucun dénominateur commun c'est un tissu
de mensonge donc moi quand me dit que
Hitler avait l'air fou quand elle l'a
rencontré au début du mois d'août mais
je ne le crois pas peut-être qu'il l'a
trouvé fou mais je sais même pas si la
osé se le dire c'était un monsieur très
élevé faut quand même pas l'oublier
c'était vraiment pas quelqu'un avec un
esprit critique et il était justement là
parce que très élevé parce qu'il n'a pas
fait partie du fameux complot de juillet
44 contre Hitler
la fameuse opération Valkyrie c'est pour
ça il était considéré comme une personne
tout à fait loyale vis-à-vis de du
régime nazi Fabien Théophile acquise
quelques mots mais c'est vraiment la fin
de ses missions je voudrais aussi que
deux mots
juste te dire que quand même les
dernières révélations enfin révélation
scholtite a été en captivité dans un
camp qui a été écouté par les Alliés et
en 1900 donc en 2017 sont parus ces
entretiens et le grand problème de
chantier c'est pas Paris le grand
problème de Sophie c'est ce qu'il a fait
à l'Est entre 41 et 43 et lui clairement
il dit mais la plus grande mission la
plus difficile pour moi ça a été je cite
la liquidation des Juifs mais je l'ai
mené avec la plus grande conséquence
est-ce que tu es intéressant c'est que
ces mémoires là permettent de se
focaliser un débat sur l'ouest une garde
une guerre d'île propre et on compte des
vécu complètement Skype qu'il a fait à
l'aise et que même reconnaît dans ces
entretiens écouter à son insu en 1947 il
a reconnu d'ailleurs je crois un bon
solstice d'avoir conclu à
l'extermination des juifs dans la
conquête et dans la campagne contre
l'Union soviétique on parle de
l'extermination de plus de 50 000 Juifs
concernant
pas comme ça en tout cas c'est ce qui
est
c'est vraiment très court très
rapidement c'est je suis quand même
toujours étonné que la résistance n'est
pas mis en valeur ces éléments que au
fond vous montrez dans le documentaire
la résistance va très souvent pour
affirmer qu'elle ait eu un rôle
militaire essentiel de ce point de vue
avec l'aide des armées alliés il y a eu
un élément comme un important je suis
toujours très surpris que la résistance
du coup n'est pas mis ce fait d'armes à
son actif bah ça sera le mot de la fin
vraiment un très très grand merci à tous
les trois suite à la diffusion de votre
documentaire dans ce débat là vous
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter bien entendu nos invités
seront d'ailleurs là pour réagir à ce
que seront vos réactions à cette
émission je vous donne rendez-vous pour
un prochain dabadoc ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]